Bộ y tế vừa bán hành chỉ thị thị không bẩy sế tế trên bệnh tế,
nè mục một tháng mười năng hành hình khu trọng hay lâm,
về tăng cường công tác quản lý,
nân cao chất lượng hạt động khám bệnh,
chữa bẩy tạc các cơ sở khám bẩy chữa bẩy.
Bộ y tế cho biết,
thử dân qua công tác khám bẩy chữa bẩy trên phản quốc có nhiều chuyện biến tích cử.
Tuy nhiên, gần đây xảy ra một số vụ việc vi phạm các quy định trong công tác khám bẩy,
chữa bẩy tạm một số cơ sở y tế,
gây an hưởng đến quyền lời sự an toàn của người bệnh,
diền hình là các phòng khám tư yên hoạt động trái phép không đủ điều kiện hành nghe.
Để tăng cường công tác quản lý,
nân cao chất lượng hạt động khám bẩy,
chữa bẩy tạc các cơ sở khám bẩy chữa bẩy chữa bẩy,
Bộ trường bộ y tế đã bán hành chỉ thị,
về tăng cường công tác quản lý,
nân cao chất lượng hạt động khám bẩy,
chữa bẩy tạc các cơ sở khám bẩy chữa bẩy.
Theo đó, bộ y tế yêu cầu sở y tế tệ tình thành phố trực thuộc trung uân,
đầy mạnh tên chuyên phố biến,
hướng giãn việc thực hiện các quy định của pháp luận,
về khám bẩy chữa bẩy chữa bẩy chế trên môn quy trình kỹ thuật,
theo hướng giãn của bộ y tế đến các cơ sở trên địa bản quản lý.
Chỉnh hai đồng bộ hiệu quả các giệm vụ liên quản đến quản lý,
cơ sở khám bẩy chữa bẩy và người hành nghe.
Tăng cường công tác quản lý quá trình thực hành khám bẩy chữa bẩy.
Thường hiện nghiêm các quy định về việc các mới, các lại, ra hạn,
nhiều trình dễ pháp hành nghe, đing chỉ hành nghe,
thu hồi giấy pháp hành nghe, bảo đàn lúc quy định tại luận khám bẩy chữa bẩy
và các văn bản liên quán.
Tăng cường công tác tiếp nhận phản ánh, hiểu nạn của người dân,
thông qua việc duy trị vận hành hiệu quả đường dưới nắm,
các nên tăng mạng sã hội, hệ thống tiếp nhận trực tuyến,
và các cây thông biến khác.
Fui hợp với các cơ quan thực thi pháp luận,
tăng cường công tác thành chà, kiểm tra,
giám sát hoạt động của các cơ dơ hành nghe khám bẩy chữa bành.
Bộ y tế yêu cầu các vụ, cầu vẫn còn chức thuật,
cân phối hợp chả trẻ với các cơ quan, đơn vị,
diệu phương, thực hiện đầy đủ các nhiệm vụ liên quán đến lính vực khám bẩy chữa bành,
theo chức năng nhiệm vụ được rao.